this has been the scene at the U.S
Mexico border recently where the number
of Asylum Seekers is down sharply since
title 42 ended a month ago the Biden
Administration began to implement an
asylum ban rule that makes people who've
transited through a third country
generally ineligible for Asylum so now
they get to have a screening they might
get in front of a judge but they
generally won't be eligible for Asylum
unless they meet one of a few limited
exceptions
one of those exceptions is for migrants
who tried to claim asylum in another
country before reaching the U.S but were
turned down for most people that would
have meant applying for asylum in
Central America or Mexico where many
people don't feel safe and don't have
the possibility of integrating and so
that that just isn't a reality a real
possibility for them
migrants are encouraged to schedule
appointments for Asylum interviews on a
smartphone app called cpv1 but many
complain that all available slots fill
immediately effective June 1st the
administration increased the number of
interview slots from one thousand per
day to
1250 or 40 000 per month hoping to
reduce the backlog
immigration remains a sensitive
political issue with Republican
candidates hoping to defeat Biden next
year claiming the border is open and out
of control
some like Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
have dramatized the situation by sending
plane and busloads of migrants to
democratic party strongholds like New
York California and Massachusetts two
planes believed to have been chartered
using Florida taxpayers money recently
flew migrants to Sacramento California
one group was dropped off outside the
Catholic Diocese headquarters then
there's the other side of this which is
the worst of American values and that is
somebody
and the early evidence points to Florida
and we know where that points
who would use
innocent vulnerable people
as political Pawns
is there no shame
California authorities say the people
responsible could face criminal charges
including kidnapping Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Los Angeles